um enter a lot more spaces they wouldn't
have been allowed to and to grow in ways
that they would have probably you know
not been allowed to so it's subjective
would you say that women are happier
today
than they were in say 1920. i think
women are
confused why
um because with
i can't lie i'm confused
[Laughter]
um i think the subject of feminism has
has brought about a lot of confusion for
some women
because
a lot
of them
do not understand
the
originality of it and what is
why feminism was created in his spaces
so
um i know a lot of people that they
think they're feminists they want to be
feminists but really and truly they
don't really know what it is so i don't
know if it has helped
yeah
did you know that women didn't actually
want the right to vote the majority of
women second wave feminism right
no the first wave i would say because uh
i was i was under the impression that on
the second wave feminism uh they were
going to be conscripted into the army
and then as a
because they were wanting the right to
vote and then it was voted on and pushed
down see rolo tomasi argues that there
was only one feminism that there was no
first wave second wave third ways that
it's oh it is and has always been a
supremacy movement
and hi
i would agree with that what's your
thoughts on that
um
let me find the hold on let me find this
article
i mean yeah i mean i don't think it's
about equality i think feminists hate
men
they genuinely hate men and personally i
think it's resulted in much worse
outcomes for women because one in four
women are antidepressants does that seem
like it's going well for us
why would you why would you say they
hate men why would i say they hate you
yeah that's a bit strong isn't it
because they don't think all feminists
hate men
okay so there is a there is a feminist
who decided to do a documentary on the
male um
basically she was talking about men the
men's rights movement right which
advocates for things like child support
yeah um
men's shelters like we have women's
shelters men's shelters and men losing
everything in divorce yeah and feminists
were like protesting
this this
this video because this she was a
feminist and she went into the men's
rights movement
and then she thought oh they actually
have a point
there's actually a lot of systems that
are against men feminists don't advocate
for them why don't we ever hear
feminists talk about
child support why don't we ever hear
feminists talk about alimony why don't
we ever hear feminists talk about men's
rights issues it's always about the
women
if they really wanted equality why don't
they fight for both
because they probably feel like for a
long time
it hasn't been in their favor so
now is the time that they're choosing to
to speak on it they wouldn't care what
they wouldn't care what it means for the
man so how has it not been in our favor
when we never had to fight in wars
so okay we didn't have the right to vote
you could say that we were oppressed but
you could also say men were oppressed
because they had to go fight and we
didn't
well
okay true
but then that's why i said it's it's
subjective because
um that's one side of the argument for
enough you may not have been able to
fight
in wars um i don't know
back when you know we were more um when
wars were more common i don't know how
many women would have wanted to go and
fight in the war right
so
um in a way you could say we had an
advantage over man
yeah
yeah you could say that but from what i
understand is um
perhaps the option to
go to war wasn't there for the woman
well that's why the women didn't want
the right to vote
was because we didn't want to get
drafted because if you're able to vote i
don't know how it is here but in the us
if you're able to vote you're free range
to get drafted into the war and so once
that
law was passed that women
can vote it's like well i don't want to
vote because i don't want to go to the
war i don't want to be drafted so
so feminism it all started in 1848 in
seneca falls new york the suffrages had
200 men and 100 women um in the 1920s
they were seen as terrorists planning
assassinations
yeah they were seen like they're seen as
antifa is seen today
the suffragettes were intense
yeah
that's new information to me i i would i
would definitely say that
to feminism for me seems like a very
sophisticated and kind of sinister way
of kind of destroying people from the
inside out just from my experience with
feminism from reading that ideologies
and refining refinery29 those kind of
journalism
kind of websites they have a very very
biased
perspective and it's almost like um
a cult because you have to buy into the
overall message which is that
we were always at the bottom and then
they used that to justify this very
lopsided bias world view that then they
used to justify
more and more
extreme kind of well it's it's a victim
mentality
and i don't understand like how am i how
how am i at any disadvantage in 2022
being a woman
what do i don't need to be fought for
what do they need it's not empowering i
don't know i don't know how it's seen as
empowering you know to say that you're a
victim and then having like a lot of the
beliefs where it's like we've been
suppressed for this many years there's
any other
i don't know i don't think that's
empowering if you're really trying to
empower people so what do you think
uh
that you don't think
about like do you think women are
oppressed now in 2022
um
no i don't think they're oppressed not
in 2022
but you can argue that the the movement
of feminism
um
has led has led for it to be that way
has led
oh you're saying has led for us not to
be oppressed
i would i would argue that we were never
oppressed it was just about trade-offs
and choices
how would you define oppressed
um to the point where you
um
you're not entitled to certain
privileges
i feel like for
uh a lot of um the feminists that i know
for a lot of them it's not so much about
the argument of
um
going to wars or having children but
more so um
in
a working environment
and
the the freedom or
the right to be sat at certain tables
um they may have had the the skills the
knowledge
to to compete with the men
however they were overlooked how did
madame curry do it
madam who madam curry
i'm not too familiar with she was the
first um first female millionaire or
billionaire in the us i think milli i
don't remember if it's a millionaire a
billionaire
but that wasn't like the early 1900s and
how did she do it
doesn't seem like she was that oppressed
she could have been an exception to the
rule i'll say even in like if you look
at like british history
it didn't make sense to me that there
are like queens like our highest figures
in english history like queen elizabeth
et cetera and i'm thinking so we had
this patriarchal society but the most
powerful person the society was a woman
you know
for me it didn't really like
align
um but i'm not well well read them well
and the other thing is maybe women
didn't want to work
like i mean i feel like they duped us
because one if we just waited a little
longer we would have got